okay no thanks right now I'm stressed
out I don't know what if she doesn't
like it yeah that is gonna reflect
poorly on me for everyone and we have to
force a romantic connection on a certain
date
what's the most romantic gesture you've
done or someone has done for you on
Valentine's Day I snuck into Ariel's
room and put flowers everywhere this was
on her birthday but for Valentine's Day
men always seem to fail like that it's
simple you send presents to her work to
make all her other [ __ ] jealous
Valentine's Day isn't about each other
it's all about showing everyone else how
much you love each other
Kelsey we already talked about how much
we love each other all the time anyways
it annoys people also too bad you don't
have a choice ah what also what she
works mom oh it seems like you're in a
weird position because you don't really
know what to get her she works at home
I'm gonna help you you are I'm gonna get
a gift for your wife for Valentine's Day
from you so I'm gonna give her a gift
from me but it's actually gonna be from
you yeah oh my god this is very exciting
let's talk about budget for Valentine's
Day I really wouldn't want to go above
$50 so $50 is what we're working with
here yeah okay here's a trick that I do
when it's someone's else's birthday I
buy them a gift that also includes me I
do like that like experiences do
together oh wait I got an idea
Hamilton I went to see you in New York
without her and she got really jealous
so if I surprised her with Hamilton
tickets yeah but how much money are you
trying to spend god this is actually
harder than I thought it was gonna be
does she like I'll just get it the
Hamilton tickets what about if you can
read this bring me a glass of wine socks
I'll just take out a second mortgage
that if you can read this bring me a
second glass of wine yeah
socks so when her feet are up she likes
wine man that's like whoo I got I got it
what is important about it Valentine's
Day gift it's custom it's meaningful and
it's something that like will remind you
of that day for forever a custom wine
glass would be great set sent up so that
I can drink wine - oh very good
personalized wine glasses $19 what if we
go kiss and a moustache I am looking for
a custom to Valentine's Day gift
thanks so much net wow I hope she likes
it I'm nervous I think she'll like it
Arielle looks like there's a package
here for you I think you should open it
it's the early Valentine's Day present
I didn't pick them out oh Kelsey did
Kelsey you are very good at fitting so
that's it get someone a gift that you
can have an experience to get there you
go like drinking wine all right for
Hamilton tickets wind up in Hamilton
tickets will make anyone if you have an
extra $3,000 hey Pat early its Annette
oh yeah
[Music]